il super facile questo challenge
ciao a tutti bentornati sanità source
nuovo episodio trova gli ingredienti
slime challenge questa volta dovrò
trovare gli ingredienti slime nascosti
da le ndrine ce lo avete richiesto in
tantissimi e se non conoscete sulle
ndrine ancora meglio perché spunterà
fuori all'improvviso come funziona come
le latre challenger devo trovare tutti
gli ingredienti time è riuscire a fare
lo slime prima di essere presa dal land
riina per cinque volte
quindi o cinque giorni a disposizione se
non riesco a recuperare tutti gli
ingredienti slime isla ndrina mi prende
per cinque volte ho perso
se invece riesco a recuperarli riesco a
fare il times la ndrina scomparirà come
sempre se questo video raggiunge il 40
mila mi piace faremo un'altra challenge
trova gli ingredienti slime potete
decidere voi chi sarà il prossimo
personaggio scriveteci nei commenti
spolette che sia e ora siete pronti
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn
iniziamo subito adesso andiamo
siamo richiamo se c'è qualcosa qua
intorno
io non so se le ndrine e cieca come
premi per i gremi è cieca ma sente
benissimo
oppure se ma vero il contrario è sorda
ma fede
non lo so scrivete voi nei commenti o
comunque lo scoprirò presto
io comunque di fare silenzio casomai mi
senta ma non so se riesce anche a
vedermi comunque esploriamo un po la
stanza se c'è qualche ingrediente sliwa
[Musica]
finora non vedo niente aspetta un mezzo
guardate un po abbiamo già trovato la
ciotola questo stato facilissimo
spero che resti della challenge sarà
così facile
wow allora poggia la chat acqua sul
tavolo
evviva abbiamo trovato la ciotola e ora
non ci resta che trovare la colla la
spatola il bicarbonato e la soluzione
per l'ente
stiamo rientrando corridoio fino ai che
sto stile ndrina da qualche parte vabbè
però se la vedi a pisa mi prima ok però
che berlino non si è alleato con granny
come come l'altra volta fanalino aiutami
ad esplorare oppure che sta fuori
all'improvviso mi spaventi mi vengono in
parte
se voi vedete qualche ingrediente slime
qua in giro scrivetelo nei commenti
state attenti a controllare anche voi se
c'è qualcosa non mi sembra di vedere
niente ma non so perché ma a me sembra
che non ci sia nessuno qua c'è troppo
silenzio
[Musica]
hanno preso neanche entrati sky
forse ha sbagliato i fiori
sbagliato e turbo andare da un'altra
parte in altrettante non c'è sulle
ndrine non ci sono gli ingredienti slime
sicuramente non ho guardato bene io però
c'è qualcosa di strano
non è che magari sto giocando in
modalità boost modalità fantasma e
quindi sly ndrina non c'è forse quello è
stato per granny sia qualcosa che non mi
convince in quest'azione meglio
continuare a esplorare un po berlino
vincere sempre incontro è questo ma
arriva sempre un po strano quando
facciamo coste challenge musp allo
spaccio nelle soluzioni per reti ci
siete un'amata così velocemente ragazzi
sono felicissima sono riuscita a trovare
l'associazione talenti e super facile
questa challenge mi sembra strano che
entrino non è ancora persa ma sembra
supersemplice quindi abbiamo già un
nostro ingrediente siamo pronti andiamo
a mettere il nostro ingrediente
berlino rientrino mi ha beccato a
tantissima paura sla ndrina scrivetemi i
commenti secondo voi fa più paura
greenews le ndrina berlina miale cazzo
sotto la faccia per cercare di
svegliarmi severino 6 cercando di
avvisarmi di qualcosa perché militino
occhio un cui primo berlino stava
cercando di avvisarmi perché vi
ricordate che andava sempre nell'angolo
ma io non avevo capito che c'era sla
ndrina nascosta lì comunque è stata
super silenziosa e ancora più silenziosa
di g quindi penso che questa challenge
sarà ancora più difficile ma guardate un
po sono riuscite comunque comunque a
prendere la cova che cosa è successo ai
miei capelli merlino sei stato tu a le
carni capelli mentre dormivo
ma insomma no no no no no la lascia
lascia mai riuscito a prendere la
soluzione per lenti quindi mettiamo
l'acqua
abbiamo lasciato nella soluzione per
lenti
ora continuiamo ad esplorare e stiamo
super attenti alle ndrine perché è
silenziosissima e non mi rendo conto se
si avvicina quindi cerchiamo la piano
pianta non penso che sarà ancora nella
stanza penso che sia furba e ha cambiato
postazione ma noi proviamo comunque a
contornare la stanza magari c'è qualche
emittente che non abbiamo visto
chiediamo anche poi se vedete qualcosa
oppure che spunti fuori all'improvviso
ha detto vai piano
[Musica]
ho preso niente qua come fattori andare
mi sembra ci sia qualcosa lì
[Musica]
no
o no trend rino mi ha beccato di nuovo
ma che giorno siamo il secondo e il
terzo member card ovunque ho visto il
bicarbonato era proprio lì mas le ndrina
mi ha fatto un agguato ed era sotto
nelle sale se lei è ancora lì sarà molto
difficile prenderli bicarbonato a meno
che non è la pro un piano che mando
merlino per farla distrarre
poi io lo prendo e poi devo però
recuperare merlina scappare con berlino
in apprezzate mi sembra un buon piano o
no magari potrei tirarle qualcosa in
testa come ho fatto con il nonno di
grendi avete visto il video in cui
giochiamo trendy 2 nella vita reale
bene sono riuscite a sconfiggere il
nonno tirandoli in testa a tutti questi
pupazzi magari funziona anche il
consulente riina
oppure sulle ndrine e tipo fortissima è
immune a queste cose
proviamoci proviamo con un pupazzo
danzare
qual è la storia di trent riina se non
sbaglio la figlia di tre anni ferro voi
sapete tutte queste storie quindi scrive
the mall ai miei commenti ma se non
sbaglio la figlia di granny quindi ci
vuole qualcosa che possa fare paura alla
figlia di crediti
provo con kirby chi è qui con fiaccole
magari riesce a metterla ko potrebbe
essere una buona idea ma potrebbe anche
essere una pessima idea perché magari la
ndrina si arrabbia ancora di più e mi
rincorre ancora più in fretta e poi ho
perso la challenge finora ho solamente
la soluzione perdenti nella ciotola se
non trovo la colla non riesco a fare i
miei il bicarbonato saggiato ma la colla
ma non visto da nessuna parte
dove può essere in questa stanza ma non
me ne sono accorta ma non mi sembra di
vedere niente berlino che fai
ho capito una cosa quando un merlino va
da qualche parte vuol dire che se la
ndrina è lì perché anche questa volta
lui era vicino alle scale
quindi se sto guardando sotto il letto
forse strina e sotto il letto
vogliamo che si entri in are the wall e
di controllare
no per fortuna non c'è sulle trina qua
sotto forse non c entra qua sotto
bene o male allora dobbiamo prendere il
bicarbonato e colpire ting li na con
chiedi
[Musica]
si no
no no non è vero
no potrai farti andreini partente la mia
testa
berlino penso che sia un gioco per lui
no no no no no
[Musica]
prima porto queste parti sono riuscite a
trovare la paletta non so come ho fatto
a non vederla prima era sempre di forza
nel fermo si vuole o anche la paletta a
questo punto manca solo il bicarbonato
alla corri vinto la challenge ma prima
devo tirare questo in testa con termine
[Musica]
di cioccolata o no berline fatto li devo
andare con parole al vento
[Applauso]
io mi sento nel mio film fosse dalla
nostra parte
[Musica]
pensavo che merlino fosse stato preso
dal sole ndrina perché sentivo dei
rumori strani e lui è sceso per le scale
ho sentito anche le urla this land riina
in realtà merlino ha solo rincorso kirby
e ovviamente love boat con i suoi denti
e durato poco kirby berlino ha già
distrutto almeno l'ho recuperato in
tempo non so se effettivamente arrivato
in testa al free entry e onu perché
quando abbiamo scelto le scale non ci
può essere magari nascosto dentro questo
armadio ovunque la cosa positiva è che
sono riuscito a prendere il bicarbonato
guardate ora prima cassaro la colla
l'unico problema è che non ha idea di
dove possa essere ma cerchiamo assieme
ok continuiamo l'esplorazione forse il
viaggio nel momento di aprire qualche
porta
proviamo qui tutto bene
forse dietro questo punto
quando c'è niente
se non sei nessuno
le scale
[Musica]
ci sono quattro tempi non abbia mai
pensato di uscire dalla porta
l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi ora ci basta
solo mettere la colla addensare tutti
gli slam centrino mi ha beccato di nuovo
guardate un po sono comunque riuscito a
prenderla alla colla perché quando mi ha
beccato avevo già la gola e bande 20 ok
dobbiamo non perdiamoci in chiacchiere
facciamo subito lo slime prima che se la
ndrina si renda conto che ho rubato
tutti gli ingredienti e che posso farla
scomparire
iniziamo con la colla ok oddio no camera
non capire anche tu allora con la subito
sbrighiamo i nostri accorga dai scondo
ok lo ammetto pochissima così riesco ad
attivarlo super velocissimamente poi sei
bravo solo un punto
bottino messo proprio che sarebbero idea
di uomo di primati proprio da insperati
spaccati scoppiati sbrigativi che ti
frega ma no entrino stati fatti per
fatto attivati oddio ma che devo miss
carlo è uscito un po un po strano ma non
centrano il trend rino sta entrando
nonostante lo trovo sia uscito ma sorta
di gomma da masticare un po masticata
sono comunque riusciti a fare sparire di
vetrine ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta con
il nostro mini slime è stata difficile
questa challenger molto paurosa perché
il trend riina è molto inquietante bar
ce l'abbiamo fatta
se volete vedere la seconda parte
lasciate un bel mi piace e ora vi lascio
qua 4 caselline in cui potete vedere
tutte le nostre altre challenge si trova
ad ingredienti slime o granny oltre
challenge e cliccate sul casellina che
preferite tra queste quattro e buona
visione
ciao